our next guest picked a good year to
have his best
year of his career it's a contract year
for aaron jones 1104 rushing yards five
and a half yards per carry and he joins
us now on behalf of old spice aaron
welcome back how are you pal
i'm doing great at you
doing great great to see you great
season we know it fell short of where
you wanted it to be and look only two
teams are going to make it to the super
bowl from your perspective though can
you bring yourself to even watch the
game after you get so close to being in
it
uh yeah i could still watch it uh i mean
it definitely hurts not being in it uh
especially
being being again twice and uh not
making it to the super bowl it does hurt
but
um you know i'm a man i can
take my loss and i can go back to work
and
learn from that game and
continue to work like i said
to build build my game back up so i can
eventually help my team get to that game
so
i'll watch it i'll cut it on and i hope
to see it again
it is impressive that the packers in
consecutive seasons had 13-3 records
consecutive seasons get to the nfc
championship so i mean we're not taking
away anything from that but when you
look at the ultimate the ultimate
outcome is it harder to deal with what
happened last year where the game didn't
really seem all that close against san
francisco or is it harder to deal with
this year when it kind of felt like it
was there for the taking
um i spent more so this year you know um
we had opportunities and then myself as
well
didn't play as well as i wanted to so
um
just just that and then um got injury
couldn't go back in the game and uh
couldn't be there for my team so
i'll say a little bit more this year
yeah did it feel like a different year
this year i mean compared to last year
where you you did you guys feel i heard
roger say at one point we kind of felt
like we were somewhat the team of
destiny i mean does that add to the the
the hurt of this game
uh it definitely does you know um
i think a lot of players like we didn't
plan that you know the next day we were
having exit interviews and
none of us were ready coach wasn't ready
nobody you know we we all expected to be
there we like you said we felt like it
was
destined for us to happen uh we have put
in the work and um we were right back
where we wanted to be in um
just didn't work out for us the way we
wanted it to but uh it definitely did
feel like it was like
our year
yeah no doubt and i i can't imagine i
mean hey i never got to play in one of
those games to have it hurt but i know
it hurts i mean here's the other thing
that i can't stand right now about just
the the talk around the green bay
packers i want you to tell me how you
feel about it you guys lose the game
right and it's all be it's aaron rodgers
he choked he didn't play good it's all
his fault everybody tries to blame him
he can't get over the be like what you
as a teammate as a friend of his like
what what do you say to that to kind of
talk
that's ridiculous i mean he played a
great game uh
he did everything in his power he was
making exceptional throws and
uh i mean
against a great defense too as well so
um they got guys on that side of the of
the ball they get paid as well you know
there's no slouches over there but uh
right i don't know i i think that's
don't i don't pay attention to that but
he had a great year he played very games
he said multiple times since then that
on that fourth down play fourth and
eight where uh the team was down eight
points he was surprised that that uh the
field goal was kicked what was the
general feeling among the players at the
time that all happened where the field
goal unit went out instead of going
forward on fourth and goal i mean i know
you were out of the game at the point
but just what you heard then what you've
heard since what was the thought among
the team generally
i think just a little surprised as well
you know we had gone for it most of the
uh most of the year and fourth down but
um
i i didn't disagree with kicking the
field though you know it still gave us a
chance to win as well or gave us a
chance to be in the game just need to
get a stop uh so i i don't disagree with
that
but it was a little shocked that we
didn't go for it
you know when aaron spoke to the media
after that game he created a storyline
that lasted all week long because he
talked about the uncertainty of the
future for plenty of guys on the team
myself included and that took a lot of
the focus off of other guys you're one
of the guys whose contract's up here we
go no no extension um you're going to be
a free agent in
six weeks if they don't work something
out where do things stand are there
negotiations do you think you're going
to stay with the packers do you think
you're going to go to the open market
right now i mean my agent and uh
the packers are they're gonna sit down
and talk but uh i mean i have no clue
i'm just gonna let let it be in their
hands and
uh
it's probably all ready to know and
it'll all work out the way god wants it
to and
so i just wanna i'm just ready to play
football i'll get back on the field and
uh get that ugly taste out of my mouth
yeah i know and i mean get that money
too so you can get another one of those
chains i like that chain you got on
right there man that looks good can't
hide money mike
uh um
i do want to uh i've lost my train of
thought being a dummy here okay now this
is what i wanted to go with
the the buccaneers their defense you
know just talk about them a little bit
give us your scouting report those two
middle linebackers like what they do to
their defense is about as fast as they
get at that position just kind of wax
poetically about them if you can
definitely like you said uh
the fast probably the fastest that you
do get at that position uh
faster than the running backs i think uh
yeah definitely around like four or four
at the combine or something like that so
um they can all move um they have their
aggressive front um penetrating front uh
playmakers up there too
um
and and they is is they have a good good
backing as well but uh i think their
linebackers are kind of what makes it go
they're d line they're they're front
seven um right
and they they just they they don't get a
quarterback a lot of times so that means
you don't have to
cover um for all that long in the back
end
would you say that was and i know i'm
putting you on the spot here but when
you just talk about you know
vida veya and sue and the two guys on
the edge and like the best front seven
you guys played this year
uh
i think uh i think yeah
i would say the
yeah i would say yes that's the best
front seven we played this year yeah
okay
aaron what would you say the team needs
to do to get past that championship game
level and get back to a super bowl
um i think we were right there just
gotta execute um
down the stretch and
um play better you know
i mean we had everything we needed uh so
just gotta execute and play better
if you ask me
um
if if
for some reason it wouldn't work out in
green bay do you carry around a list of
destinations where you'd like to go
maybe teams that need running backs
maybe places you'd want to live teams
you've always wanted to play for
anything like that
one team
yeah one team come up
[Music]
[Laughter]
well done tell us more about old spice
since we're talking about it
uh definitely i'm happy to partner up
with uh old spice you know old spice and
myself we know that 2020 was a now a
year for a lot of people but we also
know uh and learned that you you
persevere uh through the face of
uncertainty and with that being said uh
we want to give men that confidence to
get up off that couch we know it could
be hard to tackle that or any problem
and uh so we came out with a
new line of deodorant called dynasty is
uh as cologne in his long lasting uh
scent
uh the cologne i i don't even wear
cologne anymore when i throw this on
because it has that that scent and it's
long lasting all day
yeah
smell ready for anything with this
i mean so i i need it right now man i'm
a little sweaty under here already so oh
it comes in handy when i'm in el paso it
is it gets hot so i'm like
uh-huh yeah i hear you i know all the
way uh that i know i love that deodorant
with that little cologne smell man that
makes it just that much better i'm all
for it
it does my my niece i put it on uh
yesterday my niece is walking around the
house and all day she's like you smell
good you took another shower and i'm
like now i see usually walking around
the house telling me i stink
[Laughter]
all right that was really time to put
you on the spot all right
don't give me some diplomatic bull crap
answer all right none of that crap all
right i know your family i'll come find
you all right
who's gonna win the super bowl who if
you had a pick chief's bucks who you
gonna go with
i really want to see a good game yeah
thank you that's a diplomatic bull crap
answer now get it no i really i'm really
not going for anyone i'm torn like
i'm torn uh
does it add to it to like the box
where you're like i'd like to see the
team that beat us win the super bowl or
are you still mad at them where you're
like ah screw them i'd hope they get
beat
see it's i'm 50 50 on that right but i
so i'm cool with patrick mahomes and i'm
cool with ronald jones so it's like
i'm like good luck to both of you like
may the best man win okay all right i'm
not i'm not in it so
may the best man win okay fine i'll let
you skate with that one fine
but no i want to share the game
yeah
go ahead yeah i mean hopefully hopefully
that's what we get you know we've been
spoiled in recent years a lot of them
have been good and hopefully we'll get a
good one this year and hopefully we'll
see you in one whether it's playing for
the green bay packers
some other team or team old spice if
they start an nfl team one way or the
other we hope to see you playing on
super bowl sunday congratulations on all
your success and all the best going
forward aaron
yes sir thank you get paid aaron jones
go get that money do it man you're the
man
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports